let me ask you one question
I've asked you this question before
and it comes up a lot people know that I
I've interviewed you all these years
I've known you almost 30 years and
people ask me and say to him why does he
have to fight so hard why doesn't he
pick his fights a little more why does
he have to call people names and the
only reason I think this is an important
question is because these I think
everyone here tonight is likely voting
for you right so
however
it's going to come down to those people
that maybe you're in the middle a little
more and the argument that they make to
me is if he would just tone it down a
Hair Stop a little the name calling hang
on
I said it's their question leave me
alone all right
um that that it might help you with
swing voters and and that are needed for
you to get over the Finish Line it's
already hard enough electoral vote wise
for a republican to win what do you say
to them okay you ready and I say this to
everybody
I won an election it was unprecedented
we beat somebody that supposedly had it
made and you know they probably did
things in that election too they were
shocked but I came into office and from
the day I got in I was under siege by
people that have been in Washington for
many years put in there by many
different presidents in most cases
people that were against me like they
spied on my campaign they did all sorts
of things I was under investigation and
under season so will my people and if I
wasn't tough I wouldn't be here right
now I guarantee you that if I didn't
fight back I wouldn't be here what they
did was so bad and they've been caught
now so far nothing's happened to them of
consequence we had an attorney general
Bill Barr who didn't have the courage to
fight he just didn't have the courage he
was a nice man but he didn't have the
courage he lost his courage when they
wanted to impeach him they said we're
going to impeach billboard they didn't
even know why there was no reason to
impeach him he didn't do anything wrong
but he didn't have the courage we need
courage in this country or we're going
to lose our country hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else